move that aside move this over here put
this in a box here toss this over here
get rid of that throw this out of the
way it was 1995 friend of mine doing
scientific glassblowing calls me up says
hey can you help program my glass oven
I said sure so we work at this
Mackintosh at programs glass the
southern so the temperature goes up down
and everything he says well how do you
want to get paid and I say yeah don't
pay me let's build something let's make
a Klein bottle so they say oh yeah let's
all work together we sort of weld the
stuff and we're building this out of out
of glass and we finally finish it I say
this is a glass flying battle so I say
I'll go over to the math department
Berkeley and I'll show my friend Ken
rivet this bolt this Klein bottle he's a
topologist still actually appreciate it
I say Ken look what I made in the sky
he's a professor of math he looks at he
says that's a glass Klein bottle I've
always wanted one how much money do you
want so I say I'm no hundred bucks he
reaches into his pocket and starts
counting out $20 bills I'm stunned so
suddenly this five watt lightbulb goes
off in my head you know if I make a
bunch of these I can probably sell them
the problem is making a bunch of them
you know it takes me two or three days
to make one so I call around glass
companies glass shops how much would it
cost to make like a bunch of them I want
the price to be low enough that I can
sell them turns out making one or two
isn't going to do it making ten or
twenty isn't going to do it I have to
have like a thousand made Monde over
check this out
under my house is a
is my little forklift robot to go pick
klein bottles from stock tilt the thing
um if you look carefully at it let's see
if I actually show this this is just
homebrew this is only incidental this is
not klein bottles is how to run a
warehouse really this is the lift
mechanism for from a car window from an
old Pontiac car so I went to a junkyard
got a window tilt everything's made from
junk the up-down that's an old electric
drill that I got four five for five
dollars the wheels you know their little
motors drive the wheels around let's
tilt this up lift it so here's my here's
a boxes oh hey and yes there are klein
bottles in here and indeed indeed this
is a box of throwaway client boughs
things you know things that have flaws
on them but i don't care about that the
main thing is there are lots and lots of
bottles
it's the footprint of my house I mean
it's let see hey go back go back go back
let's drop this off from here on out
you're going to have to look at a TV
camera because you have to appreciate
that there's lots of bottles and heading
over to where I store bottles under my
house let's see there are lots in lots
of baby klein bottles in boxes under my
house and lots and lots of medium-sized
klein bottles under my house the reason
for having so many bottles isn't oh I
gotta have you know in case somebody
orders a lot it's so that in
manufacturing a lot of them I can keep
the cost low enough that I can sell them
turns out that small
production runs are real expensive so if
I can just have one production run save
enough bottles for the next ten years so
notice now there's a both brady and
cliff both are being seen by the rear
camera of my little forklift robot hang
on me how you do behind you as a cat
okay I'm gonna say no going out cats
gone don't worry about that sir I've got
the shot now if you come around towards
me
goodbye yeah have you got something
you'd like to sell online maybe not
maybe you just want to start your own
blog or a podcast maybe just start a
cool website to share photos or your
interests no matter what you want to do
Squarespace provides the perfect
platform to make that happen
they make setting up and maintaining a
website so easy so you can get on with
the important job of actually just
creating content whether you're a first
timer or re clever coder you'll find
everything you need to get things up and
running literally within minutes I run
my own blog using Squarespace and I 110
percent recommend it and importantly
your Squarespace made sites will look
good on both computers and mobile
devices without you having to think
about it and that's really important
these days if you want to check them out
go to Squarespace comm slash numberphile
and you can actually get a free trial
and this is a free trial with no credit
cards or anything required and just have
a look at how easy it is that's what I
did and then if like me you decide to go
ahead you can get 10% off your first
purchase seriously folks 10% that's
Squarespace calm and slash numberphile
so you get the 10% and you know they
came from here
seriously folks worth a look the
Squarespace build it beautiful walk up
and face to the camera I'm trying